[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vivre une expérience de glisse
directement à proximité pari impossible
vous me direz bien si c'est possible ici
à villennes-sur-seine le club week-end
glisse vous accueille au sein de sa base
nautique pour des activités on en parle
avec son gérant alexis séné clause
bonjour alexis mon genre déjà ici on est
dans un cadre un peu exceptionnelle on
peut le dire c'est la scène qui nous
permet de faire ses activités exactement
tout à fait mais très proche de paris on
est à vingt minutes donc on est
directement sur la selle on est sur un
petit bras mort
vous voyez le bateau
qui est là qui ne sert à faire des
sports nautiques c'est destiné
exclusivement à sa éventuellement des
petites balades et on peut pratiquer
tous les sports nautiques tracts et on
va essayer de sport aujourd'hui deux
pratiques wakeboard ou ex heures exhaler
la différence entre les deux voilà donc
deux sports tractés voilà vous avez par
exemple une planche de wakeboard c'est
encore assez connu on est proche du ski
nautique donc on est tirée par le
par le bateau avec le palonnier des
chaussées directement sur la planche
voilà donc après le principe c'est de
sortir de l'eau de rester tractée par le
bateau de faire des figures sur la vague
donc ça c'est pour le wakeboard
hexaglobe riesser second auxerre fait un
peu différent la pratique à peu près la
même on
on sort toujours avec une corde en main
beaucoup plus courte on a à peu près à 3
4 mètres du bateau on tire beaucoup
moins vite et le principe ensuite donc
là vous avez vu pas de choses pas de
chasse aux pieds donc on met directement
les
les pieds sur la planche on se rapproche
du surf traditionnelle qu'on connaît en
mer tout le monde peut en faire et ce
que même si on est débutant peut
s'initier avec n'a fait ça commence à
partir de 7-8 ans sur du c'ur du
wakeboard wake surf c'est un peu plus
compliqué ski nautique on peut commencer
encore un peu plus jeunes 6 7 ans et
après s'est dessinée à tout le monde
bien sûr c'est parti pour test
[Musique]
c'est parti pour l'embarquement sur le
bateau qui va me tracter durant les
activités notre terrain de jeu
aujourd'hui la scène bien sûr au niveau
de l'ancien pont de poissy et comme
c'est une première pour moi une certaine
forme d'appréhension se lit sur mon
visage
[Musique]
je débute avec le wakeboard après m'être
équipe et j'écoute avec attention les
conseils de julien et puis c'est la mise
à l'eau
et le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est
que les débuts sont laborieux
[Musique]
oh
pour vous de la neuvième tentative
j'arrive enfin à sortir de l'eau et à
tenir sur la planche une poignée de
secondes la fatigue se fait ressentir il
est temps de faire une pause et
d'observer
[Musique]
vient l'heure ensuite d'essayer le
wakesurf cette fois ci les pieds ne sont
pas attachés à la planche le premier
essai est ratée puis miracle enfin une
tentative réussie j'ai réussi à tenir
debout une minute
vous
[Musique]
et ça y est je viens de terminer ma
session est justement avec moi il ya
julien mais qui est gérant associé qui
m'a un peu guidée dans cette initiation
comment tu m'as trouvé juin pour un
début c'est jamais trop évident mais
bien sorti et a réussi à sortir henric
surf donc c'est déjà pas mal en général
toujours dix quinze minutes assez
complexe au début mais là de la session
suivante mon avis tu seras debout et
puis tu pourras déjà bien t'amuser
surfer la vague est donc là j'ai essayé
le wakesurf le wakeboard il ya d'autres
activités qui sont proposées par week
ends well donc on peut aussi faire du
foil du ski nautique du mono et puis
après on a aussi l'espoir un peu plus
tranquille du type paddle histoire se
balader sur les sur les canaux un peu
plus tranquillement quoi et donc on les
activités que j'ai testé pour une
initiation de 15 minutes comptait une
quarantaine d'euros une cession au
groupe d'une heure 150 euros et les
activités ici à cette base nautique de
villennes sur seine sont ouvertes
jusqu'à fin novembre